possible
with a course from a premier University
[Music]
true champion who upskilled to win big
how big a massive hike that transformed
my life Danish change gears pretty early
in the race
but Russian wanted to explore more to
get ahead isilio snicara simply learned
from mechanical engineering to a data
analyst and a podcaster in his free time
Sr career transformation live
it felt like a piece of cake that is
simply awesome what's also awesome is
that no salt
nitin didn't choose a quick fix
just added data science into the mix
nitin how did you change the game worked
on real industry problems to become the
real deal a joint family a regular job
responsibilities but nothing could stop
nithin from getting ahead what an
all-rounder de Hoya Knight with flexible
make it right bashing a situation
you too will find your way to get ahead
when you simply done
simply learn get ahead with simply learn
[Music]
came from
see folks have joined from Singapore
West Bengal
nagpur I can see someone has joined
from UK as well Southampton
I can see this Shah I can see Sajid from
hello welcome everyone I can see someone
has joined from Chennai as well because
I can uh see your email IDs here if in
case you're introducing your name is not
visible please do let us know your name
as well I can see
from gurgaon
and Abdul is saying good evening good
evening folks
good evening good afternoon good morning
where are we joining from
and I can see uh Muhammad joining from
Kerala sudesh from Pune uh awesome keeps
keep the introductions coming in and
we'll just start in few minutes we are
right on time and today's free resume
masterclass will be about how you can
design the perfect resume for overseas
opportunities in eiml and also we'll be
covering the IIT campus program in AIML
as well towards the end
so I'll be talking more about the agenda
and setting off your ground rules as
well before we start
okay I can see the introduction still
coming in uh for folks asking about the
recording we'll be sharing the recording
uh post webinar you'll be getting that
over uh your email
in case you want to go through it again
welcome
if I'm pronouncing and I'm only in right
please let me know okay okay
welcome welcome everyone
uh so for fork so we'll have some
related assumings uh for this session
for review uh we will be basically
sharing those resumes live for review
and we already have a speaker here with
us amitendra srivastava who will be
reviewing those resumes and we'll be
talking more about the skills and
projects you know uh and tools you can
add to your resume in order to amplify
it for overseas opportunities
I think uh I I can see most of the folks
have joined for folks joining please
keep the introductions coming in
okay fine let's start with few ground
rules so uh you can put down your
questions in the Q a box in case you
have any questions as you can see uh we
get so many messages on the chat so we
definitely are going to miss your
questions uh you will putting down here
on chat so please make sure you put down
in the it in the QA box uh folks who are
not not familiar with the QA boxing Zoom
please immediately go and check out it's
beside the chat uh section only so you
can just go and put down your questions
in the Q a box uh and we'll be we'll be
taking those questions throughout the
session but we'll have a special
duration for the Q a part so don't worry
about it I'll make sure that your
question gets answered by amitil and you
need to make sure that it is ability to
aim that's all and I think someone asked
about it the session is being recorded
yes it's being recorded and you can
expect a follow-up email with the
recording link and bonus offer uh you
also will be getting the webinar
certificate if you're interested for
that you need to stay till the end of
this webinar also uh if you want your
webinar now with your full name so
please make sure that you give a proof
of request attendance for this webinar
in the post webinar survey so please
fill your full name there now uh so this
program is powered by simply your
world's number one bootcamp uh we are
very proud that we have digitally
skilled uh folks over the last 13 years
and we have professionally trained over
5 million plus Professionals in 150 plus
countries and we are very proud of that
so thank you for joining once again uh
let's go through today's agenda so we'll
be getting to know uh more about you and
we'll be doing live resume reviews
and also the program introduction for
PCP IML by IIT kanpur also we'll be
going through skills tools projects for
eiml which you can include in your
resume as well in much more detail after
the live resume review and also taking
you through the enrollment steps of the
program and as I said there will be a
special duration for the Q a part so
let's start the session
so before we start as I said we would
love to uh know a little bit about you
so you can see a quick poll on your
screen uh so we would love to know how
much experience do you currently have
how many years of experience do you
currently have you can see four quick
options on the pole here
and you can quickly submit your response
there by just clicking on the option
which is the most suitable for you in
terms of experience and submit again
it's that easy I can see I I think
almost uh 90 of the folks have already
wanted so folks are pretty fast here
that's great and I'll just give 10
seconds more only for a few of the folks
who have not shared
um the answer on the poll uh and I can
see the introduction still coming in on
charts so that's great that's great we
have gotten a very active audience here
and uh I can see folks are giving
introductions uh from wherever they're
joining from so that's great
okay I I will be closing the poll in
five seconds a few folks who have not
would at least immediately go and vote
how many years of experience do you have
so five four three two one let me
interval and share on share the results
with you
okay as we can see that uh most of the
folks who have joined are currently
studying or have zero to three years of
experience and uh most of the folks also
have more than five years of experience
and few of the folks have three to five
years of experience so that's great uh
now we know that you know folks who have
joined us come from different different
set of experiences so that's great to
know
uh now uh speaker
is here with us uh will be taking us
through the free uh AIML master class uh
would you like to give your introduction
I mean
thanks Russia
uh good morning uh good evening to
everyone depending on the time zone this
is Sami theme and truly delighted to be
here with all of you today my name is
amitend and just to give you a brief
intro what I do I I hold an MBA degree
from from Pune uh is I see a spoonie and
had the privilege of accumulating over
16 years of invaluable corporate
experience my journey Incorporated world
has been defined by my passion for
analytics and statistical Concepts and
this passion has driven me to excel in
the field of article product development
as well as training delivery and over
these years I have had the incredible
opportunity to work with some remarkable
organizations and individuals and uh I
also had the privilege of training
corporate organizations in data science
artificial intelligence and machine
learning accumulating over 4500 hours of
training experience and it's been deeply
rewarding experience to Empower
professionals with the Knowledge and
Skills to harness the power of these
transformative Technologies
in addition to my training Endeavors
some
I'm also running a company called
intellectica which I'm running since
last 10 years it is into Data driven
Solutions and uh
I have a small team of 17 people and we
create data driven solutions for
different companies and in terms of
training uh just to name few clients of
mine associated with Caltech University
program and Purdue program in
association with simply learn where I
take care of their pgp program and
overall I have more than 200 clients
where I have done training program in
the past
so that's in a nutshell what I have been
doing
well thank you so much for your
introduction uh now let's move on to the
resume review but before that we would
love to know why are you attending this
resume review session today so you can
see a quick pull on your screen so uh
you can let us know why are you taking
this resume review session today what
exactly is your expectation you have you
can see four quick options here this is
the McQ uh post so you can choose
multiple options here and submit it
and I can see folks have started voting
in for why exactly are they attending
this webinar on resume review session
today
uh I'll just read out the options as
well uh for folks who are still thinking
about it uh so the first one I'm seeking
to transition into a career in eiml and
the second one I want to improve my
resume and showcase my AML skills uh and
third one being I'm interested in
learning which projects and experiences
are valuable for a AML role and the last
one I want to understand what AIML tools
I can add to my resume
uh also if the polls uh pool options do
not cover your your basically reason to
attend the resume review session today
uh you can let us know in chat as well
so please feel free
I'll be giving five seconds more for the
poll because I can see most of the folks
have already voted uh so I can see equal
equal votes for almost all the options
so that's great I think I think uh we we
will be covering uh most of the things
for you for to help you out so I'll give
five seconds more so five four three
two
one
okay let me share the results uh I I
think we can see that we have gotten on
almost equal Imports for all the options
so folks who are looking to transition
into any a little career so you're at
the right place folks who basically want
to improve your resume and showcase your
aims skills I will be talking about the
skills part and also folks who are
basically interested in learning which
projects and experiments are valuable
for an analog I will be talking in depth
about that as well and also basically
you won't understand what tools you can
add here as we make as well for aim
opportunity so that's great I will be
covering all those things in the session
today so now let's start with the resume
review session so basically how to
design the perfect resume for overseas
or Portugues in Ein
let me know
sure
okay guys so let me give you a little
brief on on when you're designing your
resume basically some
some some basic things that you have to
focus upon is you have to start
you have to choose the right format and
these days because of the uh
ATS that you talk about I don't know you
guys have heard of it or not but uh
nowadays what is happening is a lot of
companies have applicant tracking system
and these applicant tracking system will
basically look for automatically it will
look for CVS and resumes and it will
read it and then probably it will
extract information out of it so you
have to choose the right format however
if somebody is asking you to send the
resume then probably you can stick to
your PDF document but the safer side if
you ask me would be a Word document that
would be the best format to stick to
because ATS works very well with the
with the word document and at times I
have seen that people have complained
about their PDF format which was not
getting picked up by the atheists then
uh some basic thing uh don't forget to
start uh start with your objective which
is very important summary or objective
uh give a brief summary or the objective
statement that highlights your career
goals and what what you bring to to the
table that's very important and and
customize this section to match the job
that you're applying for remember one
thing that the resume that you are
building is is not not something which
is one-time exercise and once you have
created you can send to all you have to
customize your resume every time you're
applying for a particular company or a
particular organization so when you're
writing your objective there also you
can you can tailor that section to match
the job you're applying for
then not to forget I like your
achievements whatever small achievement
you might think it's a very small or
little thing you have done but highlight
that right in in bullet points to list
your accomplishments and
responsibilities
begin each bullet point with a strong
action verb which is very important what
kind of action you have taken don't just
write simple like a simple sentence
start with the action word that's
important then quantify your
achievements wherever you can and this
is for the folks who are experienced
they can do that they they will have
some kind of kpis which they can mention
that how it has uh how they have helped
the organization so quantify wherever
you can and uh another thing I would say
is customize your resume for each job
application by emphasizing relevant
skills and experiences that has to align
with the job that you're applying for
and then use the keywords from the job
description to match the employer's
needs so basically that's what I'm
saying that every time you apply for a
job you have to change your resume here
and there a bit so use you pick up the
keywords from the job description itself
and uh incorporate those keywords in
your in your resume
and then you have to finish with your
education your skills section
professional experience that generally
we do and uh for uh remember to keep it
concise aim for a resume length of one
page for Less experienced candidates or
freshers and up to two pages for those
who are who those with the more
extensive experience so maximum two page
otherwise it becomes very lengthy and
generally if you talk about people who
are recruiting they don't look for they
don't they don't read entire things so
you need to be very concise uh
formatting is very important uh use a
consistent font and style throughout the
document and very basic things I'm
telling you here but I I see that
sometimes people make mistake on that
always proofread your your resume
carefully or if you are if you if you
want to take someone's help do that
proofreading is very important uh
include relevant extra if you want to do
any kind of Publications
presentations or volunteer work you if
they are relevant put it there and
create a very honest resume use keywords
and if you talk about from data science
and and machine learning field
perspective your technical skills should
mention the programming language that
you are comfortable with it could be
python it could be R and then also
emphasize your Proficiency in data
manipulation and Analysis libraries like
mention that you are very good with
panda as our or scikit-learn or or
probably some data visualization
libraries C1 or matplotlib so mention
those those Library as well that you are
very proficient in that then also
highlight your experience with machine
learning Frameworks like tensorflow or
Pi torch generally I think tensorflow
would be one it will be using as I
mentioned data visualization tool then
you also mention your machine learning
expertise describe your experience in
developing or deploying machine learning
models if you have any if you do not
have mentioned the projects that you
have worked as as an intern or probably
you have you have done some summer
internship or internation internship
where you have worked on a project
highlight that or probably you have done
a Capstone if nothing else so highlight
that entire that what you have done what
kind of algorithms you've worked with it
could be regression classification
clustering Association rules whatever
you have done mention that and if you
are if you are familiar with any deep
learning techniques then you mentioned
those as well
also emphasize uh what kind of data
pre-processing capability you have uh
you can you don't have to elaborate but
you can mention certain data
pre-processing technique that you are
very good at feature engine technique
probably or for that matter if you have
if you have scope you can mention about
model evaluation also so when you
actually explain writing about your
project or Capstone mention all these
things that how did you evaluate the
model okay so all that is very important
then
then if you are having certification and
all don't don't miss out on putting on
that it's a good thing to create a
GitHub portfolio also which is very
handy you can solve certain problems
which are there in open Forum create a
nice portfolio on GitHub and mention
that on your resume and people who are
who are freshers they can start with the
uh summary or objective statement put
their education then uh mention your
education section uh detailing your
degree University graduation date and
GPA mention any relevant coursework that
you have done then mention your projects
that you have done uh in your in your
college in your University and mention
mention any any personal academic
project that showcase your data science
skills or machine learning skills
describe the problem you addressed a
method that you use tools that you used
and the outcome and insights that you
have gained from that particular project
that's pretty important and then mention
your technical skills as I mentioned
certification hackathon that you have
participated your portfolio so all this
you can you can mention in your resume
this is just to give you a little
overview
okay so that's what you can do
okay I think
understand what exactly is the biggest
concern right what is exactly uh the
biggest challenge when it comes to
making a resume for eaml so uh folks
before we start the resume review you
can see a quick poll on your screen uh
so you can see basically what aspect of
your AIML resume do you find the most
challenging uh to perfect there you can
see uh five quick options there
and you can let us know basically what
is the biggest challenge uh when it
comes to basically preparing and yeah I
will resume in
okay I can see folks are pretty quick
and uh
I can see we can we can see the pose
moving and let's let's see which is the
basically most challenging uh one
meanwhile I can see folks have already
started adding questions in the Q a box
so just to remind you if you have a
question uh please do let us know in the
Q a box we'll try to take it throughout
the session uh as many questions as
possible but we'll have a special
edition for the Q a part so don't worry
about that that will be towards the end
of the session and also about the
webinar certificate you need to stay
till the end of the session in order to
get the webinar certificate so also I
think someone has asked that question as
well so I'm just reminding that once
again
I'll just give five seconds more for the
poor because I can see almost 95 of the
folks have already voted so five four
three two one
so let me quickly share the results okay
as we can see that uh tailoring the
resume for a specific job role uh being
the most challenging uh task when it
comes to basically making an airline I
highly totally agree with it not only in
AML I think it's in every category of
job uh you try to apply for and
showcasing AML projects effectively I
think we'll be talking about that so you
are in the right place highlighting the
relevant technical skills and I can see
if you votes for crafting or compelling
summary or an objective and a few folks
supported for demonstrating domain
expertise so thank you for sharing that
I think uh let's start with the resume
reviews remember you can answers to all
these questions yep I hope you can help
you out with that so uh moving on
sharing the resume is
sure let me just quickly share the
resume is I need to stop sharing my
screen and
share the resume is here
just give me a second
you know folks if you have any questions
related to the resume in general related
to aim and please do let us know
on the Q a box
I am quickly sharing my screen I'm just
opening up the resume
uh also uh folks who have submitted the
resume for this session uh we have made
sure your personal information is
basically blurred it's not visible so
please don't worry about it in case you
have shared a resume with us for this
session
let me quickly start sharing my screen
for the first resume
okay
is it visible the screen
yes yes it is
I think I can
yes the first one that that you have
shared is sentence so here when you see
the the educational background has been
put on the on the top and then you have
the work experience generally people who
have
who have experience they should put the
work experience on top but before that
as I mentioned earlier what you should
do is you should start with your summary
you should write the summary or the
objective whatever whatever you feel
like so you should start with the
summary like you might write that
experience data annotation specialist
keyword with a background in computer
science so whatever you feel like so you
write a summary over there explain what
your proficient at what you're really
good at like you might talk about
labeling tools that you have used or
probably uh skill in in data collection
on annotation that you have all that you
can mention in your summary
and then you can also add a line that
what you're looking forward so that that
would be your summary so write a concise
summary of your work so that when
somebody is looking at it they they read
it and they understand what kind of
resume they're looking at in the sense
that what what you bring to the table
that's what I mentioned earlier
so that's important when you look at the
educational background State away it
doesn't give you the idea that that what
you're really capable of and you might
be really really capable of with that
that information is missing when I look
at the see me straight away and once you
write the summary then you go for your
work experience and mention what kind of
work experience you have so so if I am
not mistaken if you scroll down a bit in
Russia
yeah so so link code Labs role is data
annotation specialist
so so over here you can you can again
write things like when you're saying
data collection or data analysis uh
rephrase it like like a action words
like you can say you can write it like
utilized labeling tools for data
collection and annotation related to
electric circuits or you can write
annotated and labeled image uh video
text and audio data using various
internal software programs so you can
say collaborated with the data scientist
and so on so right in this particular
manner is what I'm saying here so so
user action verb which is very important
action words which is very important in
your roles and responsibilities when you
are mentioning do not miss out on that
that's very important it gives you a
very good understanding on what you are
capable of similarly next part that you
have written is is I think uh
can you scroll further down
so Vista engineering Solutions I would
say the same thing over here also
whatever you are writing write in a just
rephrase it what you have written and
make it little more concise uh
so Vista engineering
to write the
details of it and responsibility as I
mentioned in that particular format and
similarly
uh if you scroll further down
yeah so this is fine what you have
mentioned now system skills when you are
writing is pretty good but you need to
put in a bullet form and I would suggest
that uh put the educational background
uh over there again in a normal you can
write in a tabular form or in a bullet
form whichever way you want skills you
write skill set over there like what all
techniques you are we are really
comfortable with like you can mention
annotation technique as a group than
data categories as a as a group or you
can also mention your your proficiency
level in python or or oops Concepts all
that you can put over there okay and
and that's what I would say on this
particular CV so start in that
particular format start with the clear
and concise summary then work experience
put in the bullet form that you have
done but add rephrase those rules and
responsibilities that you have mentioned
there mention the technical skills
education then add your certification or
achievements if it's there
and don't forget to mention your uh
skill set under which you will have your
annotation techniques which was that's
what your main role is at the moment
technical skills and all that so that's
what you can do
uh awesome uh I think central if you can
let us know in chat here in case you
have any more questions we'll move on to
the next one now so this one is by
samudra
so uh see it we can review this one
so
so uh yours looks a little uh
summary you have given which is nice and
uh this one if I'm not mistaken looks uh
more like a LinkedIn profile that we
convert into a resume which is which is
nice nothing wrong in that but I'm just
saying that you can create a little more
comprehensive one so probably you can
start with your
objective statement that you have
written a summary so add over there the
the act the objective part also make it
a little little more concise on the
summary front
and uh
and and uh so objective could be
something like this I can think of or
you might write it like uh
uh aspiring electronics and
communication engineering student with a
strong passion for technology
particularly in the field of machine
learning and data science so that's how
you have to project yourself and then
you can write in and that seeking
opportunity to apply my knowledge or or
techniques into into Innovative projects
something like that you can write and
then experience you have mentioned over
here which is fine but you have not
mentioned your roles and
responsibilities as I mentioned even if
it's your LinkedIn profile there also
you mentioned the uh what kind of roles
and responsibilities you have uh under
each of the experience section that you
have so you should mention that that's
important and it should highlight your
your your working working knowledge your
style of working and all that's what and
the technique that you are using so
that's what you have to do there and
if you scroll down education you have
mentioned which is perfectly fine
education you have to also mention your
cgpa I would say
and then you also add
your technical skills section which is
on the on on the top I think left hand
side right uh Russia
so top skills you have mentioned uh AI
uh servers Cloud applications I would
say when you say AI it becomes a very
broad category you need to specifically
mention within an AI field uh what kind
of
skill set you have so you will have set
of a skill set which will more on a
Concept side like you might be very well
well versed with the machine learning
algorithms classification and then you
need to also mention on the tool side
like what kind of tools you are
comfortable with like you might mention
python or R and within python or R which
libraries you're already proficient at
so you you can create all that and
certification you have mentioned which
is a good thing so so you need to
mention a technical skill little more
elaborative in a way more more elaborate
manner so mention the programming
languages mention some more things about
machine learning algorithms and even
when you're talking about Cloud
applications so mention the the tools
and the techniques that you are using
over there it could be you're talking
about say any database any web
technology that you are mentioning
specifically mention which technology
you are talking about or or which kind
of cloud service you're talking about
are you working with AWS or gstp or
anything else
then certification you have mentioned
which is good and if you have any other
other stuff that you might be thinking
is not very important but mention that
and uh
yeah that would be all objective then
you have to put your
put your uh experience in a little more
elaborative Manner and technical skills
which are not not very clear within AI
what you are doing or whether the cloud
applications what you're doing you need
to specifically mention what you are
doing over there
that I mentioned in the earlier CV keep
that also in mind and and redo it
uh thank you so much Kinder for your
review let us know on chat here or in
the current box if
now let's move on to the next one uh I
can see folks asking on the chart here
they also want to share the resume for
review uh so we already have basically
shared a link uh when you were
registering for this webinar and we have
gotten basically this selected resume
from there so I'm so sorry we won't be
able to maybe do it right now but I can
help you out with something else you can
put down your questions you have you
know daily to your resume decay in the
Box it that is something we can help you
so now we're moving on to the next one
this is by Oishi Das
yeah so this looks uh uh a little more
uh detail if you see here you have
languages mentioned what languages you
are good at skill set dbms you have
mentioned webtech then uh Version
Control you have mentioned cloud
services you have mentioned so that's
good and recent projects you have
mentioned customer relationship
management app uh so oversaw the
development of a user-friendly I would
say change a bit of of your format I I
I'm thinking it might create a problem
when you when you send a CV to some some
companies which use some ATS which will
automatically read your CV so if you
have two paragraphs sometimes it creates
a problem I'm just saying okay but if
you're if you're sending to some
individuals this will work perfectly
fine then once you will have a single
paragraph it you will have more
explaining a particular project in a
little bit more detail it doesn't become
little little more uh
uh what you call too many too much uh
too many lines too many words in in a
concise space so you'll need to look and
look into it so customer relationship
management CRM app looks good what you
have mentioned there again as I
mentioned that the first sentence is
fine oversaw the development but the
second sentence you need to again use
some action words and if you think this
is in in in addition to what you have
mentioned in the first sentence keep it
there only or refresh the entire thing
and you have tools to these days that
can help you in terms of rephrasing all
that good thing you have mentioned is
that you have you have written what's it
what are the tools used uh in in CRM app
that you're talking about now Django
will be within python framework so you
can mention that way
the chess club website you have
mentioned
uh so there also I would say uh you have
mentioned design to empower which looks
fine
and uh
you have also given the link for the
GitHub repository which is pretty good
so you have a good GitHub portfolio
that's what I was talking about then you
have chat GPT Android
that you're talking about so there also
sentences are are good but if you look
at the second sentence again you need to
rephrase it you can say something like
utilize the power of open AI chart GPT
so you start with that utilize the power
of opengl open AI GPD don't write it
harnesses okay so we start with that way
that you have done something on that
particular part rather than you have
just plugged in something here and there
okay then you have mentioned about qsdam
exam portal
so there uh again you have mentioned I
think you're working on that right can
you scroll down Russia
currently working on this project but
give a little detail about it what
you're exactly doing over there again
use action verbs don't forget about that
that's important then certification is
fine achievements you have
uh I think you have mentioned on the
right hand side now you have to go up
Russia
scroll up certifications you have
mentioned all of them and you have also
given the link for that that's nice
and then you have achievements and this
is what I was talking about when you
when you read a resume like this some of
us might have some problem going through
one paragraph and then moving to the one
section of it and then moving to the
other section which is the right hand
side we have this habit of reading from
left to right in series when I'm talking
about resume is in in left to right
format so I would strongly recommend
that make a one one section only don't
make it two sections then you have
mentioned achievements and all which is
nice and education also you have
mentioned so I would simply say that uh
highlight your skills especially in in
programming languages and tools and for
the recent projects that you have
mentioned uh clearly explain what you
are doing with the action verbs you have
already given GitHub repository which is
nice you have mentioned list
certificates list of certifications and
achievements that you have already done
so rest of the things are good I would
only recommend that rephrase your your
your sentence so that you have mentioned
and and other thing is that whatever
project you have mentioned doesn't
highlight your capability of data
science or machine learning so I wanted
to check with you on that that have you
done anything on on that sort if not
probably you can mention a couple of
Capstone where you have worked in the
data science or machine learning field
or even in CRM when you're talking about
eventually it will collect some data
have you worked on that side but after
collecting the data uh you you will be
applying some kind of data science
concept to to gain more information or
more insight from the from that data so
all that thing you have to mention
because nobody mentions that that you
are you are working on some kind of data
science technique or data data machine
learning field so that's what you need
to understand okay
so that would be my input on this Russia
uh awesome question does if you have any
question for us do let us know on chat
here now moving on to the next one uh we
have this resume by harshad aparaj Amity
can you help us review this resume
sure
okay so harshit has given this one a
summary of experience and qualification
professional with 10 years of experience
in software testing knowledge of writing
test plan and so on and attended
training in AIML uh summary what you
have mentioned is fine uh I would say
that
what do you summaries is entirely done
but I would I would say that probably
you can think of rephrasing a bit here
and there okay so probably you can think
of
of writing that in a in a better manner
as I keep saying same same uh feedback
I'm giving on most of it that you have
to use some action verbs uh when you're
giving explanation about what you have
done so so pick up those action words
and that's what you have to do to start
with uh then uh
then
what you can try here is can you scroll
little down
my experience summary so same thing is
applied over here also if you see that
it does not have any action words that
is very important when you write an
action word it it gives this
understanding when somebody's reading
understand the psychology when you re
when somebody is reading they start
thinking you have done this particular
part instead of just simply reading it
they start getting this one this feeling
that you have done that so you need to
write it that and then when you're
writing creating test plan that's very
very generic you have to you have to
make it a little more more comprehensive
like him so that's what you have to do
and uh
and as a tester you have mentioned
analyzer requirements develop the test
cases upload test case in Mercury QC so
that I'm not really sure what all the
steps are required but if it has some
kind of technical uh requirement as well
mention that and that will be useful
then you have done you mention your key
achievements that are appreciation which
is nice education you have mentioned
so yeah I would say that uh rewrite your
uh roles and responsibilities using some
action words I keep saying the same
thing because I know most of us make
that kind of mistake and uh
and uh just uh uh take the inputs on the
on the other series that I have given
keep those inputs in in your mind when
you're recreating your CV and you're
good to go then
yeah Russia
oh sorry
I should do let us know in chat in case
you have any questions uh hashid has
responded like uh thanks so he has
responded to us great uh so now moving
on to the next one
let me just zoom in because I think the
fonts are pretty small
okay so professional summary has she has
written which is nice and uh
and uh I would simply say that this is
this is pretty good actually the summary
is pretty nicely written this one I I
read that it's nice and then immediately
she has mentioned technical skills which
is good uh programming SQL python
psychic learn and R probably you can
elaborate a bit further on that as I
mentioned earlier when you talk about
say uh python within python framework
you have you have mentioned scikit-learn
but I would say mention some more
libraries think about machine learning
Project Life Cycle or data Science
Project Life Cycle and in that what all
whatever
libraries you are comfortable with put
that like if I talk about uh data
preparation I know pandas for sure I
know data exploration uh matplotlip c
bond so that way you have to understand
that what is the entire flow and that
way you mentioned the library so start
with pandas numpy matplotlips he born
then you read scikit learn and suppose
after that you have also learned about
deployment part or evaluation then what
all libraries you might use you might be
using a as simple as flask for your some
deployment which is fine but mention if
you are if you if you're if you have
Proficiency in that or probably you're
using ml ml flow for that so whichever
you are comfortable but you can mention
tools I have seen you have mentioned
numpy pandas and and I'm just
elaborating on that that you can further
mention what all libraries you can you
can say you can you can use in in Python
uh management system you talk about
rdbms and you talk about uh elt and ETL
pod process I would say uh mention the
the Frameworks also which you are
comfortable with you might be using
MySQL or SQL server but overall if you
know rdbmsu that all is is is is the
same one in the same thing data
visualization Tableau power bi Google
sheet smart plotly but in once Excel
that's nice to see Google Cloud Scala
scrum jira join then you mentioned uh
experience
and accelerated collected translated
developed so see this is this is a
perfect example of how you should write
your experience you have mentioned all
the
all the right thing in a sense that uh
you have used certain words which is
which is indicating the action that you
have taken taken into that particular
uh job role so that's pretty important
now go further down
so data operational analyst
and scoped belt creators which is pretty
nice actually I think one thing which
was I was wondering when I was reading
it is is the knowledge about the machine
learning algorithms that you you should
mention somewhere I don't think so it's
there Russia can you scroll down I want
to see that
further down
I did not find anything on that yeah
that's right so educational details fine
soft skills so I would say one thing
that if you have understanding of data
science machine learning concept mention
that also in detail like what all you
are capable of like you might think of
mentioning uh the different algorithms
that you are good at you can you don't
have to highlight each one of them but
if you mention couple of them it will
give the idea that you have the
understanding of machine learning
algorithm deep learning Frameworks or
deep learning algorithms all that you
can mention so that was something which
I was thinking that is missing in case
if you have the knowledge and if you
have not mentioned if you are still in
process of gaining that understanding
and knowledge then probably you can
write it later but that's what you have
to do and
and and uh yeah that would be pretty
much all the things that I I think uh
this this CEO was pretty pretty
comprehensive
um
uh or in the Q a box if you have any
questions
so moving on to the next one uh I know
folks uh basically are talking about
their resume to get reviewed we'll try
we'll try to cover as much as possible
uh in this in this session of 60 minutes
so so sorry if you're not able to cover
your resume uh but you can always ask us
a question in the Q a box so don't worry
about that we'll try to answer questions
in the Q a session so we have this
resume
can you review this resume for us as
well sure
just a second
I think the folks are also not able to
see uh is it visible of books and to you
as well
uh we have gotten some appreciation for
you Amita as well uh very great and
informative session already so thanks a
lot for that so sarthak uh profiles
uh the basically the resume review just
recently it's by him yeah even Nikita
mentioned that she is going through AIML
course so that's good so amazing amazing
so uh here if you see uh sarthak uh data
analyst is a tag you have kept uh and
profile uh detail-oriented or individual
with eagerness to accept challenges
while learning and gaining experience
from the current
analysis and working with various data
which is nice and probably you can add
one more line that what you're looking
forward in in in in a job probably means
what kind of job we are looking so you
can add that one line over there that uh
what kind of career you are looking if
you're a fresher and then you have
mentioned education so which is good uh
then you have
can you scroll down
so then you have done courses so I think
it's freshers on the freshest uh CV only
so now on the right hand side you have
mentioned some links LinkedIn is there
skills data science data analysis
machine learning deep learning python as
I mentioned earlier as well that you
should elaborate a further on that like
see what happens is when you say machine
learning it's understood that when you
are mentioning machine learning um I'm
knowledgeable about those those
techniques but you when you specifically
mention few of them it gives it in more
detail about what you're capable of so
when you say python yes python I I know
Python and and the recruiter should
understand that I'm capable of working
with pandas numpy and all but that
doesn't happen most of the recruiter
will not be from the technical
background so if that it's mentioned in
there uh uh job profile that the guy
should be very good at pandas or where
should be very good with the Django
probably tensorflow they will not be
able to find those keywords on your on
your resume even though we are capable
of working with those libraries
so one thing I want to tell all of you
is that when you mention certain
libraries and and when you'll read the
job description read the entire job
description what people do is generally
I see is that when you when they look at
the job opening as as data engineer or
machine learning engineer they just
simply think they understand they have
the
they have the required skill set they
simply apply but what happens at the
recruiter when when you when a junior
recruiter is looking at the resume they
don't know that tensorflow comes under
python they don't have understanding
about that so they will match the
keywords and they will say eventually
that you don't have the skill set and
they will reject you and that's what I
was saying that every time you apply for
a job you have to again change your
resume and you have to pick up those
keywords from the job description so
that even either if it's done by
individual or even if it's done by by a
system it should match the keywords and
then it should at least call you and
tell you that you are you should come
for the interview
so that's something you have to be very
clear uh careful with and that's what I
am saying here skills when you are
mentioning you have to keep on working
on them based on what job role you're
applying for who is responding on chart
um I made the CV for analysts role for
an internship
okay uh maybe can you let us know in
chat like what is the intention here uh
like are you basically looking to
transition uh into AML career what
basically do you want to ask a meeting
please please go ahead and surprisingly
all the folks we have review so far have
joined the session so this is these are
just selected resumes out of you know
hundreds of folks who have shared with
us so that's that's pretty interesting
uh so please do let us know in chat if
you have any question for your resume
for a student and applying for analyst
internship okay understood so so then as
I mentioned uh uh give little more
detail about these uh skills that you
have mentioned and whichever company
you're applying for an internship if
they have a proper job description for
interns
go through it and then tailor made your
CV as per that but I think most of the
places internship is not entirely
defined by companies so I'm not very
sure on that but just just work on it
and rest of the things look fine
extracurricular activity okay we're just
going through the extratorical activity
and realized that you have mentioned
computer vision and and Robotics
engineer which is a pretty good thing
what you have done over there and
elaborate further on that that what all
you have done there what all tools you
have used what techniques you used put
in a bullet format and use action words
to explain what you have done and
probably you can highlight working this
particular uh activity that you have
carried on so don't take that as a lie
as a simple thing because uh lot of a
lot of machine learning algorithms are
used in computer vision and with the
robotics it is going to a different
level altogether so probably you can
look into that and and redo your your
redo this particular section
okay I would actually say that probably
you can move that as a project rather
than extracurricular activity
okay
so make it as a project don't mention as
a something which you're doing just as a
more of a hobby okay
yeah awesome uh I think uh he has
responded okay sure
now moving on to the next
uh this is by Vishal Kumar
and I'll just quickly browse through
okay there's the the second page is
blank but it's there so I think that is
that is a red flag but I leave it up to
you for the rest of the resume uh we
shall Kumar if you're joined us please
do let us know in chat uh if you have
any questions particularly you know if
you basically are trying to move towards
AIML uh so yeah
I'll just zoom in into this recipe sure
so here uh as you see there's no object
to a profile summary you need to start
with the object here then you mention
your education if you're a fresher not a
problem certifications you mentioned
certification you can mention all the
certificates that you have you have gone
through and then mention the skill set
the skill set again if you're looking
for a data science job then you should
start with something on say on the
programming platform which you're what
you're comfortable with for data
analysis what all libraries you're
comfortable with for machine learning
what libraries you're comfortable with
go through that similarly for data
visualization and the database level
what databases you are comfortable with
is its MySQL no SQL whatever and if you
have any other tools that you are
comfortable right it might be Excel it
might be our mini tab whatever
and then
in the projects if you have any projects
mention that okay I I saw the second
page was was empty so I was not very
sure about that so if you have done some
projects mention that and
and if if not I would say that take some
some some solve some some Capstone or
probably some
open source data set you pick up and and
and work on that create a good portfolio
on GitHub and uh explain what you have
done in the project and what kind of
insights or information you have drawn
from that that's what you have to do so
so that's what you can do customer churn
and all any kind of analysis you can put
there so I would say that focus on
relevant skill certification projects
related to the data science and machine
learning include any relevant coursework
or additional qualification you have now
highlight any personal project or any
open source contributions you have done
that also is fine and redo the CV and I
think rest of the points is applicable
here also what I have been telling you
earlier Okay so
so that's that's all that's that's what
I would say here uh redo this and and
don't mention your uh details like like
your I think mobile and email ID and is
it sufficient for it for you to mention
those are the things are not required
okay
good questions in the Q a box here I
will be taking those uh before that
let's move on to the slide quickly where
we stopped
uh so yeah so before we before we talk
about the program introduction uh we
would love to know what exactly is your
biggest challenge when it comes to uh
becoming an AIML expert so you can see a
quick call on your screen here so what
basically is stopping you from becoming
an an expert
so sorry for the typo and the question
so uh you can find the four options this
is a McQ question so you can choose
multiple options here as well so the
first one being I can't find a fully
comprehensive curriculum in a program
and the second one I don't have the
Practical exposure I need to become job
ready and the third one I find it
difficult to learn from pre-recorded uh
videos and the last one my work screen
won't allow me enough time for learning
so let us know what is your biggest
concern when it comes to becoming an
expert what's basically stopping you for
becoming an expert and also we have
gotten some great questions in the Q a
box and we can't wait to take those
questions so uh please make sure that
the questions are related to uh resume
in general related to eiml and also to
also relate to the upcoming program uh
by IIT Concord and Aim so we'll be
talking about more about that and the
skills and the tools and the projects
which you can add to your resume to
amplify it uh when you're pursuing an
AML job so awesome I think we have
gotten most of the votes here I'll be
closing the poll now
and sharing the results so as you can
see the biggest concern here is I
wouldn't get the Practical exposure uh
to become job ready and uh I think the
second biggest concern here is I could
find a fully comprehensive curriculum
program and uh the third one is my work
still won't allow me enough time for
Learning and I think few of the folks
have voted for I find it difficult to
learn from pre-recorded videos so thank
you so much for sharing your biggest
concern now moving on moving on to the
program review
so here uh the professional certificate
course in EI machine learning by IIT
kanpur uh gives you a comprehensive and
Industry online learning path uh you get
in the access to integrated Hands-On
labs and projects for practical exposure
we'll be talking more about that in the
upcoming slides and also uh access to
online worker Corrections with live peer
and instructor interaction and flexible
to fit your lifestyle and schedule uh
he's the program duration for this one
is 11 months and you can cover this with
by just giving 10 to 15 hours per week
and end of it all you will be getting a
certificate from En ICT Academy IIT
kanpur you can see that certificate here
how it looks like and also exposure to
leader trends like a generator bi Pronto
engineering charge ability and much more
will be talking about that in upcoming
slides Hands-On projects which I've
already basically mentioned before and
master class is delivered by
distinguished IAD can't perform like
faculty now talking about the elect the
basically the skills and the electives
you basically be getting in this uh
program uh uh in this program basically
how it basically builds your uh skills
step by step
so uh amitendra can you take us through
the scale step by step and I'm also
sorry for the typo the cyber security
difference yeah not a problem so
basically this program is a
comprehensive program which starts with
the mathematics and statistics essential
for for data science and machine
learning which has kind of become a a
very important foundational skill
because when you are working with these
algorithms we do some mathematical
calculation and at times what happens
you start thinking how it's working out
so that's where this Foundation is built
so you are given a foundation on
mathematical skills statistical skills
and as well as your programming
uh refreshes so that's what is done over
here and then the next section over here
which is mentioned is applied data
science with python where uh we teach
you how do we take up the data and
convert into a format which is very very
essential for machine learning
perspective so that's where apply data
science with python comes into the
picture so your basic data handling data
cleaning or data wrangling that we talk
about is taken cover over here and
feature engineering as well
so that part will be covered over here
and once you are done with that you will
move to machine learning which will
focus upon different types of machine
learning algorithms which will comprise
of your supervised unsupervised learning
and within those Frameworks different
kind of learning that you go through
then once that is done you will have
deep learning with Keras and tensorflow
which focuses upon uh predominantly upon
neural networks how do they work and how
do you implement it on the given data
that's what you learn over there so
you'll also get to learn a framework
called tensorflow which is designed for
deep learning algorithms so you are
taught that and then after that you have
Essentials of generative AI prompt to
engineering and chart GPT generative AI
has become a very important concept
these days you might have seen so many
examples of that or applications of that
chart GPD itself is a is an example of
generative AI so that's that is what is
explained to you over there what is what
is a generative Ai and then what is a
prompt what is prompt engineering and
and how do you utilize uh chat GPT with
the help of effective prompts and then
you will have your Capstone that's what
is your
all program
you're on mute I think
Russia
I pressed my mouse by mistake uh so
thank you so much for taking us to the
uh basically steps uh the electives come
as a part of the program you won't be
basically charging anything extra for
that so it is up to you if you want to
take that up and now talking about the
skills basically what are the skills
basically needed to be an aim and
practitioners can you take us through
these skills as well
sure so foundational skills you need to
have understanding of statistics and
Mathematics because predominantly all
these algorithms are based on some
optimization algorithm which comes from
either mathematics or statistics so you
need to learn that and then python it's
libraries which is a tool we are using
to carry out these calculations on a
large amount of data and apply some
machine learning algorithms that's your
foundational skills then you will have
learning methods different types of
learning methods you have to go through
supervised unsupervised reinforcement
learning within that framework you will
have your ansemble learning or
recommendation system so all those
algorithm you need to learn and then
you'll have some Advanced topics like
deep learning algorithms where you we
talk about building neural networks
which is nothing but trying to imitate
the human brain generative adversial
Network which is part of your generative
algorithms and then you also talk about
computer vision and NLP so these are the
advanced topics so basically this is
what the skill set you should have or
when you want to call yourself as a as
an AI or ml practitioner
thank you so much for taking us to that
now moving on
uh to the EML skills which basically we
covered uh which opens many career paths
uh what are the career paths folks can
take up uh you know as you can see that
there's a machine learning engineer uh
AI engineer but I'm pretty sure there
are much more categories of career paths
which folks can go for right not just
limited to these can you take us through
the career paths which they can take off
sure so basically if you if you ask me
probably it starts at data data analyst
or data engineer that we talk about so
once you start working on the data first
first-hand experience with the data you
get and the skill for data engineer that
you need is is you should have
Proficiency in data manipulation tools
like it could be SQL it could be
probably working with the Hadoop or
Apache Spark
and then you should also understand the
data where housing and ETL processes
understanding the dbms that you have
like MySQL postgresql no SQL databases
familiarity with data pipeline is very
important which is basically uh you can
use for you can use a simple Python
program for that or you might have
Apache air flow for that or you should
also have experience in data modeling
and schema design so you're starting as
at that level so basically you are
getting the understanding of how data is
getting stored and how you are you are
curating it to to so that so that it can
be used for some machine learning
process so that could be one path that
you might be thinking that okay I'll
work on on that side of of that side of
the entire project Project Life Cycle
where I'm working with the data only and
I'm helping in terms of cleaning the
data or angling the data and then
similarly you want to move you you want
to move probably you want to do a
machine learning part so you might have
machine learning engineer as a career
path where you need to have a good
understanding of python it's different
libraries within python or any other
tool that that you might be well versed
with and then you should have a strong
understanding of machine learning
algorithms deep learning neural networks
data pre-processing feature engineering
expertise model evaluation is very
important you should understand how to
evaluate different models optimization
of the models and then probably you can
go to next level and learn some cloud
computing also so platforms like AWS as
your Google Cloud one of them probably
you can pick up and then similarly you
should also have experience in
deployment and serving of machine
learning models so if you want to choose
this particular path you have to start
with a strong foundation in detail
science and machine learning and then
you have to gain practical experience
through projects or internship or
probably do some capstones that we keep
calling then similarly you might think
of becoming an AI architect so you have
to have strong understanding of AI and
machine learning Concepts you should
know how to design AI systems and
architecture at a broad level and also
going to the minute
steps that you have to take then you
should have Cloud platform understanding
how to do the AI model deployment on
that and then not only that you should
have a strong ability of of
collaborating with data scientists and
Engineers to implement AI solution that
also is important and career path would
be probably begin with the background in
machine learning or software
architecture software architecture is
important because you're designing the
entire architecture which is very
similar to any software that you talk
about then develop deep understanding of
AI Technologies and their applications
and then you have to progress to roles
Like Chief AI architect principle AI
architect that's how it goes or probably
you are thinking of AI developers so
then you have to have
python Java C plus plus understanding
probably depending on the requirement uh
all the Java and C plus plus will be
more on the application side that you
are building and python would be on the
machine learning AI side and then you
should have a strong software
development skills familiarity with AI
libraries Frameworks and start with the
strong foundation in software
development and then specialize in AI
development on top of it that's how
we'll move there when you talk about uh
data scientists single data scientists
then you should have advanced knowledge
of machine learning algorithm and
statistical analysis uh sound expertise
in data preprocessing feature
Engineering in Python R and you start as
a data scientist again experience you
become a senior data scientist but how
do we become a data scientist then for
data scientists you have to start as a
as a data analyst probably or or a
junior data scientist if there's a role
for that gain experience on real world
projects real problem that you're
solving and gradually will move as a
data or senior data scientists that's
how it will go
uh thank you so much for taking us to
the career paths now moving on uh you
can also master in demand tools live
release Platforms in this course uh you
can see few of them in them in on the
screen python uh Keras chart GPT uh
opencv open AI gym design
uh so uh do you need all these uh
basically uh tools libraries Platforms
in order to basically become an expert
or you can start with something you know
and I start basically also I think
adding a relevant information in the
resume is also important right you
cannot just go in at all the tools right
you know right so what would you suggest
for folks who basically want to do that
or have a question like yeah I would say
this way that uh you pick up one tool
and and the other becomes very easy like
if you talk about nltk which is for
natural language uh processing
tensorflow is for deep learning Keras is
for deep learning scikit-learn which is
mentioned over here is for for your uh
machine learning algorithms matplotlib
that we use is for data visualization
floss we use for creating deployment
servers all this these libraries
underlying programming is python so when
you learn python all these libraries
will be very very simple for you to
understand and in our program what
happens you start with the basics Python
and and basics of python and and once
you start moving towards machine
learning and deep learning all these
libraries will be part and parcel of it
so you don't have to specifically sit
down and understand how they how do they
work but machine learning algorithms and
these libraries will be kind of a
byproduct where you will gain
understanding of them while using in the
in the classroom itself while while
solving some problem similarly chart GPT
has become very important these days and
uh you can you can that will be a
different tool altogether but that also
understanding is given to you how it
works or when you talk about mid journey
kubernetes and all that's for the model
deployment so one of the other you might
be pick up and you can use it like ml
flow is also a pretty good platform
which is much easier to use so so I want
to say all of the tools will be very
necessary but some of them are kind of a
mandatory now and as you progress in the
program you will get to learn all these
tools and techniques
uh that's great uh now moving on
basically to the projects I think uh we
can we have basically talked about how
you can add a project uh so we basically
have these retail production bfsi many
more projects like this which you can
come into this program and also capture
and project will be talking about uh
after this uh so how does having a
caption project which you can add to
your resume as you've mentioned in one
of the resumes right having a project
will basically help
if someone was coming from
transition to enable what would you
suggest for them in terms of these
projects we can cover through this
program
okay if I talk from a recruitment
perspective I'm looking for somebody who
has a good understanding of these
Concepts I'm fine if they do not have a
actual problem that they have solved in
a particular company or organization as
long as they have sound understanding
I'm fine with that and one way of of
showcasing that you're really good at at
machine learning or data science would
be a Capstone because our Capstone which
is there is a quite a quite a
comprehensive Capstone it tests your
knowledge right from data acquisition to
data preparation data wrangling feature
engineering model building and
eventually model evaluation so it if you
are
it will test your knowledge on all those
aspects and in doing so you you get to
learn what kind of
how do you present your finding to to
the end users so Capstone is pretty
important in terms of showcasing your
skill set that what you are capable of
and once you solve a a Capstone
automatically you will understand that
what kind of phases you have gone
through and what should I mention on my
resume once you once you once you want
to showcase your skill set so that way
it is very important
oh wow that's great now moving on to the
eligibility
to know about the rigidity as well so
you basically need to have a prior
knowledge or experience in programming
in mathematics uh you need to have a
bachelor's degree with an average of 50
or higher marks and also two plus years
of formal work experience is preferred
uh now moving on uh basically to the
global leader we have program director
so they make sure that they basically
simply love is delivering to as per
standards uh to IIT kanpur here we have
professor
we would love to know like are you
interested in enrolling into the
professional certificate program in
artificial intelligence by IIT kanpur so
you can let us know on the quick call
you can see on your screen right now uh
I will be moving on to the Q a part uh
pretty soon uh we have gotten on a lot
of questions in the Q a part and we'll
try to cover as much as possible and uh
yes we have extended uh the session by
few minutes uh by 10 minutes or so but
we'll try to cover as many questions as
possible from the Q a box after this
once I take it take you through the
enrollment steps as well so please do
let us know on the uh quick poll here as
you can see on the screen here right now
uh
so yeah
I'll just keep this Poll for 10 seconds
more also to let you know you'll be
getting a bonus offer for your
attendance webinar if you basically
enroll uh into this program now and you
can share your interest towards
enrollment in this poll here and uh
basically it'll be
understanding basically when you want to
start as well in the upcoming next
slides I think of you folks have asked
about the program fee when is the court
starting I'll be sharing that once we
are done with this
okay I can see one uh response in the
chapter already is done so that's great
uh I hope we can help you something with
the resume part if you have put on your
questions there I can see a lot of
application coming towards Amity in the
excellent session very useful thank you
thanks guys
would you uh I do have a quick survey
for you towards the invitation because
you would like to do such kind of
sessions you know in the upcoming months
so I would love to get your feedback
I'll do that towards the end I'll just
keep this Poll for five seconds more so
if you have the folks who have not voted
we have gotten most of the interest we
can see on the poll here towards
enrollment so that's great so I'll just
end this poll in the next five seconds
so five four three two one let me end
the poll thank you so much for sharing
your interests
uh you just need to follow three easy
simple steps in order to basically
enroll to this program you need to
submit an application at
dot net I'll share that email ID on the
chart after this and uh based on that
your application will be going for a
review Once your application is reviewed
you'll be getting an Ambitions offer
later from learning Consultants from
Simply learn uh with the bonus offer uh
which you'll be getting for attending
this webinar
so and the enrollment schedule and the
program fee for this one which most of
the few folks are asking about it so the
uh cohort for this one is starting on uh
21st of October and the induction for
this is starting on 29th of uh September
uh the fee for this program is uh one
left fifty three thousand four hundred
including taxes and uh we have uh Mi
financing options also available for as
low as 5220 uh rupees per month uh for
folks who have joined from uh different
countries you can go and check out the
program in your region I'll share the
link towards the end of the session and
also if you have any questions you can
always contact us at ask us at
simply.net uh just to let you know that
we have very limited seats for kohat so
we only take 25 to 30 students where
cohort in order to make sure you're
getting the uh all required attention
you know when you are basically uh
pursuing this program
so uh for folks who have already shared
their interest towards the enrollment
I'm just launching a quick poll on your
screen which you can see that how soon
do you plan to enroll into the PCP
program in AI machine learning uh by IAT
Concord you can see four week options
here the first one immediately second
one within three months uh third one
within six months and the last one more
than six until now uh folks who have
shared interest I can see most of the
folks who have shared interest who are
getting this webinar
um you can select maybe immediately I've
shared you the cover but she can join
immediately and within three months of
option if you're planning if you need
more time and folks who are still
thinking about it I would suggest to
select them within six months or more
than six months
so now because uh if you select it now
you will basically be getting the bonus
offer for writing his webinar even from
six months from now so why do why do you
want to lose out on that right so I'll
just give like 10 seconds more for folks
who have not shared yet because I can
see they have gotten most of the votes
from the folks here
so we have gotten really active uh you
know folks here a lot of application
appreciation coming in excellent session
from Lima okay already enrolled with
caltic that's great Catholic is also
great
uh okay I can see uh folks a lot of
folks have joined basically alumni as
well of Simply and I've joined here so
that's pretty interesting I'd say so
okay we'll be moving to the Q a part
here I can see that you're still jotting
down your wishes there because I can see
the Q a uh questions you know going up
so I'll just end this poll now thank you
so much for sharing when do you want to
enroll now moving on to the Q a bar
so let's start with the Q a part we'll
try to take as many questions as
possible because it's extended the time
uh apologies for that if we are not able
to take all the questions so let me just
quickly uh scroll through the questions
here
too many questions I'm just going
through it
meanwhile if you have a question you can
go and put down a question there related
to the program or AI email career in
general or anything related to the
resume as well
okay I can see one question from Raji
which is a very interesting question uh
I am from the sales background who has
enhanced his experience uh in DS and ba
uh now I'm learning eiml uh how can we
resume it give a good weight for this
transition and interest I mean can you
help us sit there
sure
so sales background and then you're
coming into into data science
so
what you need to focus upon is basically
in sales also a lot of forecasting
happen so one problem happens is that
uh okay let me give you an entirely what
you can do you can write about start
with a strong summary don't forget about
that bring in your resume with the
compelling summary don't forget about
that introduce your background your
transition to data science and your key
skills
okay then you need to highlight some
transferable skills which you can take
from sales and and and move into into
data science field in a sense you can
talk about your sales career such as it
could be same as simple as communication
problem solving client relationship
management that you do probably how you
can take that and move into into into
into analytics it could be probably
you're talking about sales analytics in
general that you they can you can focus
upon or probably even in data science
field you're thinking about about a job
role which is which is more of a
business analyst job role because that's
that is also there in data science field
all you need is is a good communication
skills good problem solving skill and
you work as a bridge between the client
and a team of of data scientists so you
need to understand what what problem a
customer is facing how how is your data
driven
technique can solve that particular
problem understand the entire scope of
work come back and then sit down with
the set of data scientists and then
create an entire solution plan how it
will work that kind of job role is also
there so so probably you'll have to look
into from that first particular
perspective but as as much possible as
as far as possible focus on highlighting
your transferable skills and then
showcase your your achievements don't
forget about that see what kind of
personal projects you have done which is
talking about data science as a tool and
and then solving a particular problem
that that you have done in personal
capacity that is also fine you can
mention that and you can personal
capitals in the sense that you have done
it for your team probably it was not
required from management but you did for
your team and the team has has gained a
lot of insights from that something like
that you can you can focus upon
thank you so much for answering that
is known chat
the question of we have no questions I
can see one more interesting question
from pallavi here uh I hope I have a
question I am a network engineer how can
AIML help me in further in my uh or
enhancing my career
network engineer
okay network engineering when you're
talking about uh AIML could could be
could be useful in networking as well so
uh it could be Network traffic analysis
and optimization that you are looking at
so it could be it could uh Ai and ml
algorithm can help you in analyzing
Network traffic pattern in real time
identify any anomalies or probably
predict potential Network congestion in
in advance that's what you can do one
one example I'm giving you or it could
be security threat detection you can
create uh models which can detect and
respond to network security threats
faster and more accurately than your
traditional methods that you have or it
could be your your very common
predictive maintenance which will help
you help our Network Engineers to
anticipate and and prevent Network
equipment failures that we talk about or
any kind of network automation you are
looking for where you want to automate
the routine Network task it could be
configuration management it will be
provisioning it could be troubleshooting
that we are talking about or it could be
probably anomaly detection it could be
natural language processing for
troubleshooting you want to create an
application like that so all those
examples that I have given as in it is
only in your domain I'm talking about
only your domain now the problem what
happens is I'll tell you like if I'm a
data scientist and if I have to solve
this these kind of problem what I need
to do is I need to understand and
entirely how networking works so what is
network engineering that domain
expertise you already have it all you
have to do is you have to gain your aim
our understanding and then you need to
Simply
combine that knowledge with your
networking knowledge network engineering
knowledge and then you can solve these
problems that I have mentioned
uh thank you so much for answering that
I hope uh pallavi that answers your
question please do let us know on chat
uh I can see one question from anas here
I recently took admission in bscs uh I
am currently a digital marketing Analyst
at a well-known digital agency I'm
thinking of Shifting my career to AIML
what will be the starting part
so uh digital marketing analyst is what
you mentioned right yes yeah
so
a starting point would be built the
foundational knowledge about mathematics
statistics one key area I want to tell
all of you people do not realize uh and
especially people who start learning
machine learning directly and then they
say that status statistics is not
getting used anywhere but to do overall
comprehensive analysis on the data
statistics is very essential and you
should learn about them them in detail
so start with the basic statistics and
then probably you can break it down into
descriptive inferential prediction and
prescriptive and go through them and
learn about inferential statistics
probability Concepts probability
distribution so build that Foundation
First also learn about programming
platforms remember programming is just a
helping hand we cannot do those
calculations with pen and paper so we
are using python or r or any other
platform as a calculator a sophisticated
calculator which can do the calculation
for us that's a role of python that's it
and then learn those python fundamentals
uh and and also how how to acquire data
how to prepare data and then gradually
you move to machine learning models
that's what you should do
that answers your question
okay uh let me just quickly browse
through more questions uh the questions
are still coming in
okay I can see one question that uh I am
a job Hopper work in genomics research
agriculture r d School administration
educational advisor health care and so
on uh will this school course help me or
someone with seen instability not every
job first for me for more than a year
average is 1.5 years and Max is three
years
okay so it's a quite a
diverse uh
the the term that you use job Hopper was
pretty accurate over there so I would
say when you talk about Healthcare in
particular uh a lot of applications are
there actually and uh it could be
disease diagnosis if I talk about from
Health Care genomic data analysis itself
is a is very vast and complex and and uh
AIML algorithms are used to process
analyze and interpret genomic data in
fact I have been talking to one of the
hospital in California where they have
been doing some DNA sequencing to
understand uh what kind of problem a
newly born baby might develop in in next
three years and how to solve that
particular problem